During the Holocaust.
It was a cock lived in the book and wild
concentration camp with our husbands.
She would order the deaths of prisoners
at a will and even enjoyed watching
people being tortured and kills
her home was filled with momentos,
made from human skin and it was a call
come had been responsible for more deaths
than your average serial killer.
Indeed,
she is considered to be one of the
most evil women that ever lived
bone with a maiden name.
Margaret also color her life,
had humble beginnings in Dresden,
Germany as the trials.
No one could have ever guessed that she
would grow up to be such an evil person.
Neighbor say that she was a friendly,
happy girl and she was popular in school.
Her father was a laborer and her mother
was a housewife just like on the German
girl Zillow.
Zillow would have known to cook and
clean and take care of a household.
She left school to start working at a
cigarette factory fulltime when she was 15
she began taking classes in accounting.
It's a local college and
and bookkeeping position.
It also joined the Nazi
party very early on,
most likely because she
came from a poor family.
The Nazis promise the lower class that
they could help bring Germany out of the
economic depression that they were
experiencing off to world war one.
For people who are poor and an educated
fascism seems like a solution to the
country's problems.
I said began to believe in the ideals of
an area in master race and Shannon that
feelings of antisemitism.
She mentioned like minded men who would
become a future husbands call a cock.
He was nine years older than El Sarah
and had already gone through a divorce
from his first wife who disagreed
with his Nazi philosophies.
He had a criminal record for theft and
he and his brother grew up working as
informants for the police.
There's life of grime was
actually something that
builds the thought was quite
attractive and they were married
in 1936 often Hitler came to power.
The couple were rewarded for being early
adopters of Nazi-ism went from being a
petty criminal to being handed a
position as a high ranking ss officer.
The two of them that have a up with any
sort of wealth and they suddenly had the
opportunity to become rich and powerful,
and so they took advantage
of it to its fullest extent.
Before he was put in charge
of a concentration camp,
Carl Koch was the warden
of a prison in Berlin.
He would force prisoners deep stuff
themselves into dog houses and eat out of
bowls.
They were supposed to kneel
and Bach when coke was around.
If they refuse,
they will be soon.
If a man did something wrong,
hot tar was shoved up his backside.
This sadistic torture was noted by the
Nazis and they thought his unique skill
set,
it could be useful of running
a camp filled with the
enemies of the Third Reich.
It was a cock,
wasn't turned off by the brutal
reputation that her husband had.
In fact,
she loved us and she wants it to be a
part of the process as much as her husband
did.
When she found out they were going to be
running a concentration camp together.
She even got some practice
where I get to prison camp,
cold Sachsenhausen Call Elsa Coq.
One interesting charge of managing
the book involves concentration camp.
They were there during
the construction of it,
the gate to the camp red yet m dust sign,
which means to each his own.
What they meant by this was that
everyone gets what's coming to them.
This was their own personal touch to
rabbit into the faces of those people who
they truly believed.
Does it have to be treated
less than human beings?
Book involved was the largest of all the
Nazi concentration camps and yet there
were no gas chambers for killing
people quickly and efficiently.
This camp was mainly there to
use the prisoners as slave labor,
making things that were
useful to the Third Reich.
Prisoners in book involves
were kept alive for years,
which was a lot longer than it.
Other concentration camps in Auschwitz.
For example,
the average lifespan was Amea three to
four months while they were building the
camp bills and request the family must
live in a mansion which was built on the
same property as the concentration
camp in Nazi Germany.
Men and women were given set
roles to play in society.
The perfect gentleman woman was
supposed to be happy to do housework.
She was supposed to stay strong in the
face of adversity and always loyal to her
husband's high ranking
leaders in the Nazi policy.
We're expected to be a
good example of this.
Wives of SNS offices were not expected
to do the work as much as a common German
women,
but it also Cochran Kritika new
life of luxury to the next level.
She aims to have a life where she
never had to do any housework.
She decided that the prisoners from the
concentration camps would be how slaves.
She forced everyone to address
Sarah as Kinetica Frau,
which is an old fashioned to,
I'm usually reserved
for ladies of nobility.
Elsa never lifted a finger
to do anything herself,
which may to grow bored with her life.
She decided that the prisoners should
build out a huge indoor sports arena.
They looked worthy of an Olympic event.
This was used just so she could
practice a hobby of horseback riding.
It costs over 200,000
Reichsmarks to bills today.
That would be about the
equivalent of $1 million,
but all of this back riding,
it wasn't enough to satisfy a boredom.
There was a rule in the camp that if any
prisoner even looked at the commander's
wife,
they would be shot on the spot.
Knowing this Elsa Cochran,
again dressing provocatively on purpose,
she wore tight clothing and reveal
to our cleavage on a daily basis.
Most wives of the SS officers and the
other concentration can never go to
involved with the prisoners and where
most likely in some sorts of denial about
what was going on,
but it was the cock.
She wanted to get involved and she
relished in the fact that people were
starving and dying all around time.
Elsa was about some reds hatch.
He thought a lot of ourself witnesses
say that when her husband was away,
it'll sokak would come on to the officers
to bring out a group of male soldiers
and forced them to undress until
they were completely naked.
She would all say stripped down to our
lingerie and loud in front of a yard of
sec staff to male prisoners.
If any of them even glanced at her
about eur uncontrollably became aroused.
He was immediately taken by
the gods and shot in the hat.
She specifically requested to have
teenage boys working in our home.
Seven so you lived in house say that she
was holding them to bring her breakfast
in bed.
She would be laying in bed
wearing nothing but a nightie,
just like the men in the yards.
If they even dads look at that body.
It was grounds for them being
killed considering they were well,
teenage boys,
it's very possible that some of them
simply couldn't help get aroused.
Even if they hated our guts.
Based on these stories,
we can make the assumption that she was
a sexual sadist who is aroused by the
idea of inflicting pain upon other people.
One of the households,
sevens,
Eric Hush was just 15 years
old at the time that he works,
that he said that the coc dimension
was on the edge of the camp,
so he was able to look out the window
and see free people beyond the fence
watching people go about their lives.
It felt like looking at some kind of
fantasy and t often fails envious and sad.
Wondering why he wasn't so lucky.
Elsa cock allowed him to each
two boiled potatoes every Sunday.
He would carry them back to the barracks
where the other prisoners were staying.
He didn't like eating potato skins so
it would peel them off and throw them on
the grounds,
but once he did that,
several other prisoners jumped on the
pills because they were so desperate for
it
figures.
All Nazi concentration camps had some
form of human experimentation going on and
work involved was no exception.
Doctors at the camp were poisoning people
with deadly chemicals in order to find
potential antidotes and they
were injecting homosexuals
with concoctions that
were believed to turn them straight.
Soon enough,
teasing then was not enough to satiate
hills is boredom and she wanted to watch
the doctor's conduct these experiments.
She saw this as an opportunity
to have a new hobby.
She wrote a story through the camp and
notice that some of the prisoners had
really interesting tattoos.
She approached one of the camp doctors,
Eric Wagner,
and suggested that he should conduct
a study to see if tattoos had any
correlation to criminal behavior.
Technically,
Dr. Wagner should have never said
yes because it was against protocol,
but he agreed to do it.
During these tests,
people were killed and their bodies were
taken away to be dissected so that Elsa
could keep this skin.
Also began writing a whole surround the
camp commodity men to stop what they
were doing and strip.
She would walk through
the lines of naked men,
sizing them up and examining their bodies.
But the ones with what she regarded as
the best tattoos were selected for the
medical trial and they were killed.
Their skin was used to cover a
lampshades knife sheaths and book covers.
She saw this as an opportunity to come
up with some original Christmas gifts and
commands and a group of Jewish prisoners
to do the work of creating huge
quantities of these trinkets made from
human leather during the holidays.
She would send them to ss officers who
were in charge of the other concentration
camps.
One Room even says that she used
human body parts all over our house,
like using thumbs as light switches.
According to prisoners
who worked in our house,
Elsa was having affairs with both Dr
Waldemar Hoeven and deputy commandant,
um,
and floor statue one call.
Cock was asked to leave.
The comfort is Nazi duties.
She would reportedly stay
overnight to doctor Hovind's home.
He was known for conducting medical
experiments on human beings.
So it was just a type when
cold cock contracted civil
se or did the execution of
the orderly who gave him his diagnosis.
He did not want anyone to know the
embarrassing truth about this marriage.
Some believe that they
had an open relationship
in 1942 both Carl and Elsa Kakoa taken
to courts misappropriating the funds of
the book involved camp and for the over
the top methods of torture if we're
being honest.
It's surprising that it took that long
for the Nazis to ask where the money came
from to build else's whole stadium
and for the lavish lifestyle that she
demanded.
Many of the human experiments going on
at Buka and roles were often made up on a
whim by the Cox.
This was not allowed in the audit to begin
a scientific trial would have to have
come from higher up in the Nazi party.
Medical experiments using human subjects
usually has an actual goal that would
help the Fed.
Right.
For example,
the experiments usually prove that areas
where the master race or the disabled
people who are somehow subhuman the
party wants to experiments that helps to
justify the genocide that
they were conducting,
the torturing and killing prisoners just
to look at their tattoos could ever be
justified from by the Nazis.
The fact that it also was the one who
convinced the Dr. Wagner to disobey
protocol shows just how
manipulative she was.
She has every man in her life wrapped
around her finger and she seemed to take
no issue with ruining that career is if
it meant getting the things she wanted
often being removed from that post.
A man named Herman Pisco took over.
Book Involves Elsa,
has been called,
was put in jail awaiting their trial
in 1944 the cock sweat finally taken to
court.
The Nazi judge concluded that no matter
how manipulative Elsa may have been that
responsibility nade on Carl.
At the end of the day,
he was the Kimono or off roll and he
should've had the final say and both the
manner of killing and the
campus well as the use of funds.
The judge suspended the charges
against still syringe set.
A free call,
however,
was not so lucky.
He was sentenced to death for his
crimes and in 1945 he was shot by firing
squad.
Elsa was free to go even though her
demands it directly contributed to our
husband's death.
She seemed to show no remorse and she
was even able to go back to living a
normal life.
In Germany with our three
children that same year,
American troops freed the
prisoners of bouquet involves,
they invited German people in Weimar to
come inside so that they could witness
what had been going on in the camp.
Right next door,
they saw 80,000 people crammed into a
space meant to house 8,000 corpses lying
around in front of the crematory and
American soldiers discovered a horrifying
collection of human body parts including
several human organs displayed inside
of gloss cases.
There was shrunken heads and they found
household items that were covered in
human skin.
The allies took testimonies from
prisoners who had lived in Bougainville
involved for years,
and when they heard the
stories of Elsa Cock,
she was arrested for
crimes against humanity.
At the trial,
it'll sir insisted that all of the
objects were made from goatskin,
not humans,
however,
that many of them really
did have tattoos on them.
Further,
there was a whole crew of Jewish
prisoners who testified that the entire,
they worked at the camp.
It was their job to butcher human
bodies and skin and make them into these
trinkets upon else's request.
Even though there were tons of photographs
proving there's all of these objects
truly did exist.
There was no proof that Elsa cock
or did these objects to be made.
There was only the testimony of witnesses
and that was considered heresay while
she was in jail.
In 1947 she became pregnant after
having an affair with a fellow jam and
prisoner.
She gave birth to our son and was forced
to give him away after he was born.
In the video footage of the trial.
She looks indignant and angry without
showing a single ounce of remorse for hot
pot in the Holocaust.
The United States military governor
named General Lucius d clay believed that
there wasn't enough physical evidence to
sentence her to death and he could only
give her four years of hard labor instead,
and she served her time.
However,
West Germany was not done with her.
Yes,
as soon as she was out of prison,
she went on trial for our crimes,
a third and final time,
and she was given a life sentence.
There was a particular witness,
Dr. Morgan,
who testified at all
three of Elsa Cox trials.
He later told the New York
Times that she was a Hussy.
He rode horseback and sexy underwear
in front of the prisoners and the noted
down for punishment.
The numbers of those who looked at at
Sheila rounds in our garden in front of
prisoners,
simply primitive,
but she had nothing to do with the
lampshade business and she did not deserve
such a draconian punishments.
She was a victim of horror stories.
Keep in mind to that that was the person
who was supposed to be defending our
character Ilsa call cad for
children during her lifetime.
Her two daughters and one of
our sons was raised in the camp.
Of course,
they were far too young to
understand the situation as a child.
When a son odd fin grew older and learned
just how much the world hated the Cox
family.
He felt he couldn't escape the guilt
and shame and so he killed himself a
daughters.
They were able to get married,
change their names and try
to move on with their lives.
There's another she was
forced to give away,
was named Ooh column.
He spends his entire life being passed
around to different foster homes and
never got to experience
having a real family.
When he was 19 he was working
as an insurance salesman
and decides that he wants
you to know his parents where he
got ahold of his birth certificate.
He figured out who his mother was and
read about how tron and the newspapers
after building up the courage
he visited and I are in prison.
She was very happy to see him.
She rarely if ever,
received any visitors since,
uh,
oldest son was dead and to do
daughters at a strange themselves.
It also told to the,
to everything bad said
about it was a complete lie.
He knew that since she had
helped run a concentration camp,
she couldn't be completely innocent,
but he still desperately
wanted a relationship with
his mother and he loves her
unconditionally.
He began visiting a once a month,
uconn.
I've never pushed his mother to talk
very much about world war two and just
wanted to get to know her as a person.
After a few of these visits,
he became convinced that his mother
could not possibly have committed such
horrific crimes.
She tried to convince him to
get a lawyer to set her free,
but it could not be done.
It was 1967 when she was 61 years old.
She realized that it was our last hope
to manipulate one more person to get what
she wants it and she failed.
So she tied her bed sheets together and
a jail cell and she hung herself in 1971
Ooh,
Cola approached the New York Times.
Do you tell his mother's
version of her own story?
And also that told him that those damn
liberal American courts were the only
ones who did not give her a fair trial.
The New York Times was eager to demystify
the lies that Elsa had told you.
Kona,
as we mentioned earlier,
the Americans actually did dismiss
the claims because of his essay,
and it was the Germans
who committed to that,
to life in prison.
Despite all his attempts to publish
our lives and exonerate his mother,
no one was buying it.
Ooh,
truly was the final victim
of how manipulation.
So I hope you found the video.
Interesting.
If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button
below and don't forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos
just like this twice a week.
So we hit that subscribe button.
And as always,
thank you for watching.